there is a way to get a free Tesla
Roadster it's not a scam I promise it's
not a scam
there is definitely definitively a way
that you can get yourself a free Tesla
Roadster that doesn't mean that it's
easy that doesn't mean it's possible for
nearly anybody to do but there is a way
all right listen listen wait hang on
listen to me look at me in the eyes
you're not looking me in the eyes you
need to look me in the eyes I haven't
even said what it is but look look at me
you're already not believing me hang on
hang on don't hang on her sure she
pretty butterfly all right listen there
is a way through the referral program of
Tesla you can all right shut up shut up
I'm not done
you can if you if you if you you not me
if you if you not me
if you refer someone 50 times to buy a
Tesla you can you get a free maybe it's
50 times I'm not sure if it's 50 times
or now it's like 200 times I have no
idea what but listen to me what I'm
saying this okay just because I'm
putting my referral just because I'm
putting my referral link in the
description below does not mean that's
some kind of advertising thing that's
not what this is about
hang on this is not what this about you
guys know me right you know me you know
this guy right you know me I wouldn't do
all right listen
okay just because the referral code mark
to 702 is my referral code and that's
the code that if you use that code and
when you're buying your Tesla you know
when you just do that casually if you if
you want to do it's like filling out a
survey for like a employee at a customer
service thing you fill out a survey you
put in their code
if you uh you're tough so you're filling
my cup mark to 702 I would like to
mention I am not being paid in any way
shape or form by Tesla if anything I
think Tesla would not like me to say
anything at all
in fact I'm pretty sure that everything
I'm saying is more damaging that could
ever be helpful so no they're not paying
this is not brand deal there's not
sponsored in any way but I'm gonna talk
anyway because I've got things to say
and I have a overinflated feeling of
self-importance and I'm gonna use that
to my advantage mark to 702 mark to 702
huh listen mark to 702 I just wanted to
be honest with you mark to 702 I just
wanted to be level with you mark to 702
I wanted to be really really thoroughly
honest with you guys mark to 702 I
personally have had a Tesla for about
two years now I am NOT a sports car guy
I was never a sports car guy I drove a
Ford Fusion Hybrid I drove I drove a 99
Corolla forever
I drove a cheap Honda Civic and then I
drove a Ford Fusion Hybrid and I've
never been the type that was like I
wanted a fancy car I don't want a fancy
car
i if you want to see me in a fancy cart
I rode with CaptainSparklez also known
as Jordan in his fancy car and it scared
the Dickens out of me
but I liked what Tesla tries to do I
like the ambition that they have
I like the mission statement that they
have which is to accelerate humanity
into a more refined oh shut up shut up
everybody shut up shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
up hang on shut up shut up you're not
mrs. mark - 702 is to accelerate the
world's transition to sustainable energy
boom that is the idea that's the idea
behind it and that's what I was here -
that's our that's what I like
mark - 702 a referral link down in the
comments in the description below you
get perks you get perks you get six
months of free super charging or a five
year extended warranty
all right so let me give you a little
backstory backstory is not gonna help
this situation but a back story will
help you understand I started out by
test driving a Tesla back in Cincinnati
I was just went on a whim like Amy was
with me and Amy and I we went to the
test place and we're like yeah you know
I've heard a lot about it you know I
just wanted to see it and when I drove
it you know it was a nice cars very fast
and whatever but what shocked me was the
ability for a to drive itself that blew
my [ __ ] mind like just completely I
was floored I was just completely
stunned by it I mean I like the concept
of electric cars and I like the concept
of you know moving towards more
sustainable energy I like that but from
a technological standpoint that's what
really impressed me about the car and
the idea behind that kind of really
motivated me to give it a try so either
way when I got back to LA I wanted to
really have that car I wanted it I
really wanted it and it was at a point
where I could afford it it wasn't that I
needed it but it was I spent so few
things that I actually wanted that I was
like I want to see what it's like so in
2016 I bought myself a Tesla a Model S
and it was great like the buying process
was not great now you guys prop might
know if you've seen a few videos of mine
I've been very critical about Tesla
because from a customer service
standpoint
they've been very bad in the past but
they have gotten better and that's why
at this point in time I am so super
happy to own a Model X now which I
upgraded to about a year ago and because
also I can take road trips with it with
my dog I've gone to from LA to
Cincinnati last year when I first got it
and I'm gonna do it again with chica and
Henry and Amy we're all gonna pile in
the car we're gonna go to Cincinnati and
it was just a really nice car the
charging stops didn't make that big of a
difference there were superchargers
along the whole way every time we
stopped we stopped for about 45 minutes
we were able to give the dogs a nice
walk we were able to enjoy ourselves we
were able to take her time with the trip
it did add more time but it was still a
nice Drive so with that being said what
I what I'm trying to say about this this
isn't entirely selfish this video is not
if this video is not marked to 7:02
this video is not selfishly motivated
this video is talking about what Tesla
is what it
what it represents and what it wants and
and I think it's really cool to see this
kind of thing come out of a field where
no one really thought it was gonna be
coming out of and it's cool because it
made electric vehicles cool whereas like
electrical vehicles weren't very
interesting they weren't very ambitious
they weren't very well received but then
when Tesla came along like suddenly
these cars became very very very cool
they were very fast that was sleek they
were nicely designed and they were
packed with technology and that's really
enticing to someone guy like me that's
addictive to technology I love tech like
I read up on tech everyday I'm a huge
tech nerd
that's pretty much all I do in my spare
time so what I'm saying is if you want a
roadster oh if you want a free roadster
all you gotta do is buy a car and then
you can set your referral if this sounds
like a pyramid scheme it is not this
just makes it seem more a lot more
disingenuous the more I laugh about it
but hang on okay so if you answering
that this title is not clickbait it's
not because I'm answering the question
of what the title said if you want a
free roadster all you got to do is buy a
Tesla you can get a Model 3 now they're
available they're not too terribly
overpriced and you can use your referral
link after that to recruit 50 people to
also buy a Tesla and then you would get
a free rotor boom baby bollocks get out
of your clickbait not even worth your
time anymore I'm not cliff baiting
there's no clickbait here there and
clickbait for nobody I'm a man of honor
I'm a man of respect I'm a mark 702 7 at
my mark - 700 - I am a man ok so if if
if not saying it's gonna happen if by
some weird imagination
I did get some people to click on the
link down there the
the mark 2 702 code you know if people
did I and they maybe bought some and
maybe just maybe I got a free roadster
out of a deal me r2 702 maybe I'm not
sorry I apologize for nothing because
I'm doing no wrong this is not anything
listen listen to me okay so if the stars
align the wallets open and some people
decided to use mark to 7:02 the referral
code mark to 702 in their order Motors
removed if people did that then whenever
or if ever I were to get a free roadster
I would use that for the community
because I would consider it a communal
effort for getting me that roadster I
would consider it a concerted effort by
everybody involved in all parties and I
would say that was our roadster it's
technically my it's technically mine but
I would say publicly that it's our
roadster and I would create a service
maybe I would mark to 702 I would create
a service much like uber it's a
ride-sharing service where if you're
subscribed to my channel and I'd create
an app that would make it so that you
check to see if you're subscribed to my
channel only then could you order a ride
and if I'm anywhere within two miles of
your location I would pick you up and
give you a short two-minute ride in the
community roadster it sounds pretty good
right it's like a great deal I'm such a
generous man on the hero not all heroes
wear capes
some have roadsters not all heroes wear
capes
some have roadsters
think about that mark - 702 okay so
imagine just for a moment
use your magic everybody close your eyes
close your eyes you're not supposed to
see this close your eyes
whoop now listen listen closely imagine
we're all enjoying all of us enjoying
the community roadster that we all have
mark - 702 imagine that there's an app
on your phone that appears suddenly out
of nowhere almost inconspicuously
but you look at your phone and you see
this app and you see the wondrous logo
that I'm going to build open your eyes
whoop okay so obey ignore obey or just
contacted we're gonna we're gonna Zayat
and design an app here real quick hang
on
that looks good okay so you know how
ruber was before much like my icon it's
gonna have a red background okay gonna
put this like this and then it get ready
for market
uber that is I made the McDonald's I
just made the big get ready for uber
markiplier uber please you look down on
your phone you see this icon appeared
magically oh it's um it's uh and then it
changes mark to 702 okay so yes this app
appears on your phone I liked it better
when it was McDonald no I don't like it
okay yeah that looks like ZZZ okay these
are not ZZZ there we go
mark to 702 so this app appears on your
phone when it appears you know that I'm
within 2 miles
you better click that button fast though
because the roadsters real quick so if
I'll be gone like in no time it's got
like zero to 60 in 1.9 seconds it's it's
fast as hell it is [ __ ] fast ok but
it okay alright everyone for a second
there listen in all honesty I personally
all jokes aside I actually really like
Tesla but it's not just about liking it
for the sake of the car I like what
they're doing I like what they've done
I like their mission statement I like
how they think of the future
I like how they push things along I'm
not super big into hero worship so I'm
not really talking about Elon Musk
specifically but I like what Tesla has
done and I like what Elon Musk company
has done as well and I kind of like what
do you want musk is done but this is
more about just my experience with Tesla
it's a great car the customer service
has come a long way I have a lot of
grievances in the past with Tesla and
how to order their cars and what the
customer service problem was with that
and they've worked very hard to fix
those problems it's a great car then and
it kind of gives you this idea of how
the future is gonna look because in 30
years like gasoline engine cars are
going to be the relics people are still
gonna have them people are still gonna
have gas cards but they are gonna be the
relics electric cars are kind of the
future I'm not saying that it's better
to have an electric car than a gas car
but right now Tesla is like changing the
game when it comes to cars and it's
changing the game when it comes to
people's perception of renewable
technology of alternative power sources
of different ways that you could have
what you want but in a different form
like people want fast cars if you want
faster than gas can do electrics the
only way to go so it's just a really
fascinating way to look at the future
and the model 3 is a cool thing because
the model 3 allows accessibility for it
now it's still not - it's not exactly
affordable but when it comes down to
what it's going to be it is surprisingly
more affordable than you would think to
get a model 3 at a very low low setting
this isn't even the standard battery the
standard battery is not going to be
available for a while this is going to
be like the standard battery is gonna be
even lower now this is this prices with
tax savings and like gas savings
included but you can kind of get a
picture that the future is moving
towards this the future is moving
towards this like that's what it's going
for and it's really cool what Tesla has
done to bring it about any I'm just
proud to have had a Tesla for as long as
I had I'm not exactly an early adopter
but I am one of the earlier adopters I
had the Model S before they got this new
nose cone I had the first version of the
autopilot system I've had the second
version of the autopilot system I've
done many many miles of driving on both
of them I've used super charging I've
done long road trips and I can honestly
say my car is my favorite thing I've
ever bought but that's not the point of
this video the point is to use my
referral link in the description below
get yourself a free roadster you can do
it today but you got to get a car first
so on your way to getting yourself a
free roadster why not you go
when you're buying your first one use
mark to 7:02 the referral link down the
description below to check it out and
maybe you don't know what a roadster is
all about here it is that's the one
that's the baby here we go there's the
stats all that [ __ ] ligado yadda yadda
boobity boobity here's some more stats I
don't know what these means these are
probably pretty cool huh it's like this
designed for arrow I like that I like
arrows it's a good show I've got a
removable top this guy there's that guy
they tweeted at a video just recently
about it may or may not have got me
thinking about hey way to go like this
tweet there's a good tweet no not that
twit that's a different wheat I did a
stream of oxygen not included on twitch
there it is there's good if you don't
understand this you obviously weren't
watching this tree okay it was this
video
okay so context this is the video of
people in the roadster as it launches
from 0-60 for the first time at the
announcement
[Music]
it's a yeah I don't know it's pretty
cool I'm I'm not a I'm not speed junkie
I'm not a gearhead I'm not a Motorhead
I'm not a car guy but you know if if if
a roadster just happened to fall in my
lap I would never buy one I would never
buy what I would never buy one I would
never buy one because of this I would
never buy I would never buy one but if
it just so happened to rain down from
the sky and fall in my lap and then it
could be our oyster that'd be fine
that that'd be fine I I just I could
never see myself actually buying one
because it seems like an incredibly
impractical thing for that being said
mark to 702 if you're already on the way
like if you're going out to get
groceries can you pick me up some milk
and also a Tesla you spark to 702 is
your referral code bottom line yes you
can get a free Tesla Roadster it is
really [ __ ] hard it is not something
that everyone can do but technically I
think there is a way to get a free Tesla
Roadster maybe that's not even a thing
anymore I bet I bet you know I bet
there's gonna be people in the comments
are like that promotion is going for
something Tesla I've got a tattooed on
my boob
I've got it tattooed right here to
accelerate humanity the mission to
accelerate the words transition to
sustainable energy that's my mission
saving I got tattooed right in between
my butt cheeks I've got it there it's
permanently permanent ink permanent
tattoo
so to summarize you can get a free free
Tesla Roadster but first you have to
actually have a Tesla so I guess it's
not actually free so this fusillade so
imma goddamn liar
click I am NOT click me if you have one
it's free still technically qualifies as
free if but if you don't have one then
it's not free because mark 2 702 I'm not
a clickbait I promise I'm not
and maybe this promotion isn't even here
to begin with so maybe I would click
banner and maybe I'm a liar but god damn
it mark to 702 so if you have a Tesla
you can still you can still get a free
the roadster it's it's a technicality
ok the roadster itself is still free
maybe if the promotion even still exists
but the Tesla Roadster is still free
because it doesn't matter if you have to
buy something else before it the
roadster is real free boom no clickbait
baby put that on the grave so no
clickbait no clickbait markiplier he
never clicked baited not once never no
way mark you 702 right at the bottom
other gravestone down there but yes yeah
anyway so guess I'll in this one here ok
this is in this one here so I hope I've
answered your questions for you I hope
I've raised a lot more questions in
regards to everything else in my life
but yeah that is how you do that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and mark to 7:02 as always i'll see you
in the next video mark to 702 bye bye